médecine l'échec de la première
implantation française ne remet pas en
cause l'intérêt du coeur artificiel
déclaration laconique hier à paris à la
suite du décès du jeune homme de 25 ans
qui a survécu 13 jours avec ce que l'on
appelle désormais un char vix est un
coeur artificiel de fabrication
américaine
coïncidence du calendrier ce matin à
marseille le professeur jean raoul mon
thiès présentait à la presse son coeur
artificiel le corps un daniel skis
30 journalistes venus de toute la france
ont assisté comme de sage étudiants à la
démonstration du coeur artificiel cora
mise au point après dix années de
recherches par le professeur jean raoul
manquer ce et le docteur patrick à blick
gros comme un coeur normal cora est
avant tout un appareil français qui
devra d'abord être implanté sur un
mouton et un veau avant d'être
expérimentée sur la nation
commencions plus tard nous avons voulu
faire mieux et actuellement s'aperçoit
que les coeurs artificiels qui existent
ne peuvent pas être implanté pour de
longues durées donc nous comme nous
sommes fixés des objectifs de fiabilité
surtout il faut assurer aux malades une
sécurité totale il faut que la machine
puisse ce marché des années d et il faut
aussi surtout qu'elle donne aux malades
une autonomie complète qui fait on
travaille pas pour faire un coeur
artificiel provisoire on ne travaille
pour faire un qu'artificielle total qui
apporte aux malades à la fois la
sécurité et les mêmes prestations que
une greffe cardiaque par exemple c'est à
dire l'autonomie pour nous le coeur
artificiel total implanté c'est pas en
89 les américains pour le même les mêmes
principes écologiques celle de ce genre
là pas tout à fait du même type de ce
genre là c'est de là qu'ils veulent une
certaine autonomie aux malades j'estime
que c'est impossible pour eux avant 90
lorsqu'il fait connaît dans la course
d'aujourd'hui vous est même en avance et
si vous aviez eu plus d'argent vous
auriez pu aller plus vite on a perdu
deux ou trois ans effectivement
maintenant il faut que je trouve 4
millions par an 4 millions lourds par an
si j'en avais 10 ou 12 par an on
pourrait lancer un programme qui
permettrait d'aller beaucoup plus vite
parce qu'il faut du monde il faut des
gens et plus il ya de deux cerveaux et
demain pour travailler mieux ça vaut
mais avec 4 millions par an je pense
qu'on peut arriver en 89 à réaliser
super artificiel alors ça cet argent est
bien il ya un petit peu les taillades
hambach qui nous aide pas mal et puis
les mécènes et en particulier dans ce
club une recherche pleine d'écueils mais
à laquelle le professeur mon thiès et
son équipe apporte chaque jour des
réponses nouvelles est encourageante